NARRATOR: Ambushed on a
desolate road at night,
Andrew repels a coyote attack.
But the coyote isn't alone.
As soon as I hit the
initial coyote on the head
with the flashlight, that's
when the other two, you know,
saw the aggression from
me and started to attack.
It was overwhelming.
I figured that hitting the first
one, it would have been done.
But it wasn't.
All it did was
just make it worse.
NARRATOR: Andrew
is now under attack
by three coyotes, a pack.
This is a species that has
evolved this kind of pattern,
this behavioral pattern of
increased hunting success
when you're in a pack.
If coyotes are in a pack,
they have the ability
to bring down quite
large prey, including
a herd animals, like
white-tailed deer and even
humans.
But overall, given
the number of humans
and given the number
of coyotes, it's
still a very rare phenomenon.
Why would a group
of coyotes attack
a human is a bit of a mystery.
At that point,
it was just mayhem.
And mind that it's 3, 4
o'clock in the morning.
And the only thing
I really see is
a general outline of the
animal and just the shimmer
of the light of the ice.
Humans, we are
not as well-equipped
as coyotes are at night.
They can sleep better.
They have ice shine, this
reflective iridescent set
of cells in the back of the
retina that serve to capture
light and then bounce that
light back out, so that then
the optic nerve,
ultimately, is picking
up on the light information.
So they see a lot better.
ANDREW DICKEHAGE: All
I could think about
was I needed both hands.
I couldn't do anything
with the flashlight.
Imagine, like, having three or
four people just in your face.
So I dropped the flashlight.
And I just put my hands up.
At first, I wasn't
even actually trying
to hurt them because I know
that wildlife is territorial.
And you know, I'm just trying to
get away from where it started.
And they're essentially just
kicking up off of my waistline,
trying to get up and higher.
By far and away, the
most vulnerable aspect
of any vertebrate is
the neck and the head.
That's where the brain is.
That's where eyes.
That's where the very anatomy of
a respiration is taking place.
So ultimately, in bringing
down a prey species,
they want to go for
that region of the body.
The only thing that
I really could do
was keep myself from
falling down and making sure
that they didn't get behind me.
After a while, it
really started to hurt.
There were gashes on my arms.
They were essentially just
opening up the wounds more.
One tactic that
coyotes [inaudible]
to get lots of little bites.
And the prey starts
bleeding out.
Really, all I could
process at that moment
was keep one foot in the dirt
and one foot on the pavement.
I don't want to lose
any kind of advantage
that I had in the situation.
But when the adrenaline
started to wear off,
I did start to get tired.
And the pain started to set in.
It was starting to
get to the point
where I felt like I had no
control of the situation
and that they were starting
to get the upper hand.
[music playing]